moi j'appelle à ce que samedi gilet
jaune et mouvements pour le climat
puisse marcher ensemble ya beaucoup de
voir aujourd'hui qui qui demande une
report de la marche pour le climat au
contraire je pense que c'est un moment
assez historique pour permettre à la
fois aux mouvements des gilet jaune qui
se bat contre les inégalités pour que la
répartition des richesses se fasse de
façon beaucoup plus équitable et le
mouvement du climat se bat pour qu'on
agisse pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse
continuer à vivre sur cette planète dans
trente ou quarante ans de se rejoindre
sur un certain nombre de points et je
croit notamment que la cause des
inégalités et la cause de la destruction
de la planète sont une seule et même
chose
ce modèle économique qui cherchent du
profit à court terme qui cherchent de la
croissance économique
infini et qui fait des êtres humains et
des écosystèmes des variables
d'ajustement
donc moi j'appelle à ce que samedi gilet
jaune et mouvements pour le climat
puisse marcher ensemble puisse montrer
leur unité puisse montrer qu'ils sont
ensemble déterminé à transformer notre
système économique et politique mais on
a besoin de le faire dans la non
violence
si des violences éclatent comme la
semaine dernière à paris sa fera voler
en éclats la capacité de ce mouvement de
réunir beaucoup plus largement les
français ça ouvrira à la voie à des
politiques sécuritaires qui ne
permettront pas de faire entendre notre
voix de montrer que nous sommes très
nombreux à vouloir que ces changements
existe et de matérialiser cette union un
peu historique de permettre au mouvement
climatique de manifester son soutien au
juge
en expliquant que nous aussi nous
pensons que la richesse doit être
distribuée de façon équitable que on
peut pas vivre dans un monde où il ya
huit personnes qui possèdent autant
d'argent que 3 2 5 milliards d'autres
donc les amis marchons ensemble faisons
le tracé non violente et surtout
montrons que nous sommes unis pour
transformer le système économique
injuste et destructeur de
l'environnement